lunch money plano what is our first
topic
oh hello you're right mute
as i knew i knew that you were going to
be on mute go ahead i am not on you go
ahead what's up with boris johnson
um so where's johnson resigned on
thursday bringing an end to a nearly
three-year premiership that has been
beset
by controversy there's a whole bunch of
things going on
he's his ratings are very very low john
what do you think
boris johnson yeah he's got a lot of
scandals in the news lately partygate
was one of them right why everything was
shut down he was having parties people
didn't like that there's been a few
other policies people didn't like uh and
yeah look i don't really know about a
lot of his policies but boris johnson
being out after only a few years is uh
quite surprising polina what do you
think
yeah i i thought this article was
interesting and it said that this brings
an end to his teflon era because people
thought nothing could affect him but
here we are
people you know he didn't do a great job
during covid he didn't do a great job
with
hiring people close to him that were
scandal free so
i always thought boris johnson was a
little unique
it got like a little uh uh aw shucks
vibe to him like every time something
went wrong you kind of just saw him and
he'd be like oh shucks and they were
like alright whatever like like not a
big deal and then i don't know if it's
like his haircut the way he kind of
carries himself the way he talks like
what it just always like seemed like
people just kind of expected like ah
whatever it's boris johnson uh now
that he's out i am kind of surprised
like i thought that he was kind of
teflon do we know what this means like
uh did any of the articles talk about
like what they expect to happen now that
he's gonna be uh be leaving in october
he'd appoint a new cabinet that would
serve alongside him
so he's going to oversee you up until
october and and then basically somebody
else someone else somebody else will
roll in there yeah you think that they
uh could they could put you up
hey if you guys want a better economy go
ahead
all right planet what's next was
startups
all right following a record year for
venture financing and ipos the tech
financing market is largely frozen in
2022 and companies are doing whatever
they can right now to avoid raising cash
at down rounds and other companies that
are more in the early stages they're
being forced to show more efficient
sales models and stronger revenue
retention in order to raise capital so
i mean
can
startups survive this and are you just
like unlucky if you happen to not raise
money
when things were great
well luck's not real so it's not unlucky
but
i do think that there are many venture
capitalists who have been telling their
companies
there are bad times coming raise money
shore up your balance sheet get in a
good position you know all that so i
don't know if you could claim that no
one saw it coming
but there were plenty of companies that
got caught offsides and were not
prepared
the
secret in all of this is good companies
can still raise money right now
it's the bad companies that can't
and
people think that's a harsh evaluation
but most of these companies are bad
there's a very high failure rate in
startups and so you've not only got to
be able to create a great team build a
product that finds product market fit
but also you've got to uh essentially
exist long enough where you go through a
period where you're losing money that's
why you raise the capital you burn a
bunch of money and you get to the other
side you hit profitability and growth
and the truth is that just lots of
people don't make it lots of companies
don't make it through that process and
so venture capitalists know that going
into making these investments that some
of them won't make it uh but i think
founders are uh
bill they were building companies that
were based on there's plenty of capital
out there i can just go raise the next
round raise the next round raise the
next round and they're getting a little
bit of a uh a surprise if you will that
maybe you can't go raise the next round
maybe there isn't as much capital as you
thought there was and so they're having
to quickly adjust their strategies uh in
order to uh to compensate i think what
do you think john one in ten startups
don't survive the long term right 110
startups can't weather the storm they
don't have enough capital they have to
become profitable i think that's the
best advice for these companies i saw
kevin o'leary the other day talking
about if you're not profitable within
the first 36 months
it's a hobby it's not a job anymore at
that point um i actually agree with that
that more and more people you have to
have good business fundamentals
otherwise people aren't going to want to
invest in your business obviously tons
of uh
private markets are notoriously illiquid
so people are very scarce during times
of recession to put their money in
private markets so it is a little bit
harder to raise as a startup
pelina
one one more thing that i thought was
interesting is do you remember when a
billion dollar startup was so rare that
we would call it a unicorn well last
year the number of financings of
startups valued at 1 billion or more
almost tripled to more than 600 last
year so i mean that tells you everything
you need to know i think that's right
what's up with starlink
okay so starlink or spacex is getting
approval to bring starlight starlink
internet to airplanes and rvs
and that will
expand the customer base of the company
which so far has been focused on
providing roughly 100 per month internet
services to homes
so now on the move you can get starlink
i think that this is a no-brainer and
this is going to be highly disruptive to
a lot of different industries uh
obviously spacex did not start out as an
internet company they started out as a
reusable rocket business but once they
figured out that it was cheaper to do
something like this they built the
satellite constellation they beam the
internet down
what an unlock if all of a sudden you
can have high-speed internet if you're
on a plane if you're in an rv if you're
driving if you're at home if you're out
in the desert if you're just
sitting anywhere in a developing nation
game changer for so many different
people to simply have high-speed
internet that's reliable that can be
accessed anywhere
this is going to be disruptive i think
is a great term for that if you're on
the go and you need internet starlink
will be the provider within 10 years i
think they're going to be the they're
going to be the category leader they've
been in front of this stuff for years
now there's going to be no more mobile
hotspots on your phone stuff like that
there may still be an existence but
people won't use them as frequently when
you have available starlink available
where you can pay you know 100 or
whatever um and get access to the
internet on a boat on a train on a plane
in your car doesn't matter um i think
everyone will have this eventually
they're definitely going to have to
shrink the size of like the receiver or
the antenna uh whatever they call it uh
because it's too big right now it's
probably like i don't know maybe like
the size of my chest uh in the actual
size of it uh of like a human's torso if
you can get that down smaller smaller
smaller and eventually if they can get
it into like the size of your palm or of
your hand and then you could bring that
anywhere
now all of a sudden it's not gonna bring
the whole you know kind of uh physical
hardware you just throw it in your bag
does price wear you at all it's like a
600 equipment fee plus over a hundred
dollars a month
same thing as tesla is you start out
with the sports card and then you bring
it down over time make it affordable so
what do you need you need to bootstrap
it right is you start out at the high
end of the price point and then you
bring it down over time as technology
gets better and the unit economics allow
you to lower the cost and eventually you
know my guess is that they'll have it
even cheaper than internet today uh for
most people that'd be nice
but but also but also if planes are to
provide it i'm sure that there could be
a discount et cetera et cetera so you as
the consumer wouldn't necessarily pay
all that
good
completely agree all right what's up
with salaries okay so
a salary
so uh this is kind of a interesting
story there's um in chile chile
um an unnamed worker resigned and became
uncontactable after he was paid
approximately 330 times his salary due
to a payroll error
he was meant to be paid 545 dollars
instead he got paid 180
418
and so then he like vanished without a
trace
hey sophia
what do you make all that noise for
are you saying that you agree oh there
she is are you saying that you agree
with the gentleman who took out his 330x
salary and said peace and they cannot
find him they cannot contact him
trust me
i don't think they're going to find him
i don't think they're going to be able
to contact him and i wonder legally if
uh
if he is allowed to say well they paid
me the money so do you remember that
citigroup and revlon thing that happened
uh i think last year a few years ago
somebody sent money to somebody by
accident they meant to send like you
know a few million dollars still a lot
of money but they accidentally sent 900
million dollars to creditors and some of
them tried to keep it right they were
there's like rules around if you expect
a wire expect something to be deposited
like how it works and if you can keep it
or not
and who ended up getting it uh some
people actually ended up keeping it
other people return the money but
they're still in uh litigation but in
these situations you know what i think
they should always do listen you made a
mistake but hey man liz we'll make you a
deal we'll give you three times the
salary give us back the other you know
whatever 330x
so that we could get some money back i
love that he offered his resignation
like he resigned and then became
untraceable uh but now the company has
filed criminal charges against him but
no arrests have been made
i mean
the other thing i always uh wondered too
is it worth it i don't know what the
actual amount of money here is but like
is it worth it going on the run becoming
like a fugitive that sounds kind of
crazy if you're living paycheck to
paycheck and someone deposits a million
dollars into your account on a mistake
a lot of people are going to cash that
out
yeah oh i i understand i understand yeah
but but it's just uh uh
you hit the fork in the road of your
life
and you decided to take left instead of
right you decided to commit a crime yeah
well is it a crime
if somebody sends you money you didn't
take it from them
right like that's what they're gonna go
that that is ultimately where they get
into these debates of like
actually if you walk down the street and
someone drops money on the floor by
accident and they keep walking and you
come up on the money if you pick up the
money is that a crime i don't know what
the answer to that is but like
but i mean that's basically what they
did they dropped the money in his
account
right and so when you start looking at
it like there's a lot of debate in these
situations uh
and people are saying yeah like up for
debate
all right planet what's up with space
sports
okay
so
there's a small dad's head by the way
a little bald head just sitting there
she's chewing on a on a
i don't know charger right now um so
space tourism has arrived and the next
frontier is space sports
and there's been a lot of talk about um
like uh z what is it zero gravity uh
athletes
come on this ain't real no no it is
because now that if space yeah the idea
of zero gravity athletics has a long
history astronauts trapped themselves to
treadmills for two plus hours a day
while in orbit to avoid bone loss due to
the lack of gravity
so it's it's been uh it's been discussed
and it will probably be attempted
john what do you think space sports uh
i've never heard of this before it makes
sense that astronauts and other people
in space want to keep up their physical
uh well-being but i don't think anytime
soon people are going to be playing
organized sports in space uh one there's
just not enough people up there to have
an organized game in space and two i
don't think it'd be very fun to watch
i am
i think that this is complete nonsense
what zero
zero gravity sports like if people want
to do something here on earth whatever
like whatever fine you guys go do that
there is nobody
who's playing any sport
in space in the next decade
how do you know
let me knock on wood real quick uh yeah
i just don't think that's happening
if you can travel to space
i think it's a possibility listen you
can travel to space all you want but
guess what happens when they leave the
iss they got a rope tied to them so they
don't float away
yeah when they do spacewalks not all of
them they use comp uh propulsion systems
to move around up there come on come on
it's like rocket league in real life how
many people in space right now they got
like six people
y'all talking about building sports we
got six people in space ice cube big
three three on three listen y'all y'all
can tell me whatever you want they got
six people in space there's almost eight
billion people in the world and they got
six of them in space
yeah but how many new people like has
been opened up in this market in the
last two years because of what blue
origin what's zero
zero taking up civilians in the space
that's not real space they couldn't
leave the actual uh uh space station
they just went in a hot air balloon ride
like come on that's not real space
if you can take somebody with no
training and they get on and you
basically just shoot them on a really
high arc and they kind of sort of come
close to the edge of the atmosphere
that's not real space
space sports get out there outside of
the earth look back be able to see the
whole thing go out play sports whatever
that ain't happening anytime soon
but it's it's on the table
i'm sure it's some yeah look if we're on
mars like technically mars if there's
sports being played that would be space
sports be on a different planet that'd
be marsh sports well could be mars
sports as well but my point is just we
got six people in space right now
right out of eight billion people
they can't even figure out
how to get up there and back
every day
how many launches are there to iss a
year i don't know let's see how many
launches to iss
uh
uh every year what do you think john
launches to iss um under 100.
yeah it doesn't even uh
the iss mission called expeditions
usually last around six months there are
three to six crew members on board at
all times
if you got three people with sport you
go and play checkers
uh and professional astronaut crews come
from the us russia japan canada and
europe um
the longest someone's been up there is
215 days mike lopez algeria
uh
and it doesn't say how often they go but
if they're going for six months at a
time
maybe they go once a quarter well i mean
we couldn't as america couldn't get
there for years and years we used to
hitch rides on other people's rockets
yeah it's just again i i appreciate it i
like the idea it sounds amazing i do not
think people are going to be playing
sports in space i am shocked at how
against this you are but i just want to
leave the people with a little something
instead of calling them athletes we can
call them astroleads that's what it says
in the article not my word
it's pretty good astrology did you you
came up with that no no no it's in the
article oh all right that's fine
the uh uh there's a kid somewhere who
that's their dream is not to make it to
the nba or the nfl they want to be the
first world champ well actually you're
not even the world champion at that
point you're the uh
yeah you had to be the galaxy champion
people are making good points two people
was enough to do boxing or ufc
come on now that's a sport
and if they and if they hit each other
if i see a video of two astronauts
fighting
i would lose it
you would watch though right
100 base sports are born let's go
so whoever figures that out elon's like
let me figure out how to get the
satellites to beam the internet
down so we can get the video feed
right if you can figure out how to get
two astronauts but they can't be in the
iss it's gonna be outside yeah it's
gonna be outside like i mean let's put
the gear on
i mean if you saw a video of two
astronauts straight up whooping each
other's ass outside the iss you 100
would send it to a friend maybe the most
viral moment in human history
but then the question becomes what if
they get hurt do they have cornermen
who's the referee like you need more
than just two people
all right ladies and gentlemen i'm just
expl yeah zero g combat would be next
level planar thank you very much we
appreciate your sophia behave for your
mother